cinéma toujours avec la sortie attendue
mercredi prochain de podium de yann moix
inspiré par son roman il s'agit d'une
évocation d'un sosie de claude françois
passionnés excessif incarné avec talent
par benoît poelvoorde parce qu'elle
deschamps patrick boies selon lui les
boutons de manchette en étoile pour
cette [ __ ] je portais à la foire aux
asperges de tiji en février 95 podium ou
l'histoire d'une dépendance d'un type
accro à son héros cloclo bernard
frédéric jadis le plus grand soucier de
claude françois reprend du service dix
ans après pour un contenu au grand dam
de sa femme un seul juif est quelqu'un
qui n'avait aucune personnalité il peut
en revanche compter sur le soutien de
son ami couscous lui-même sosie de
polnareff
d'après bernard était de retour enfin
une nouvelle tournée vers la reprenne
eric et c'est vers la lettre vous dire
que je n'y arrivais au stock de france
d'un côté j'ai rappelé dans un évier il
est dans son on est dans le monde de
l'art en france ils sont des gens qui ne
sortent pas de l'enfant je vais pas me
dire c'est ça qui me touchent moi j'ai
ces gens là ils ont une obsession
ils vont jusqu'au bout et rien qui les
attend s'ils fidélisent je voulais pas
faire un film qui se moque de qui que ce
soit sur de gros coeur l'intérêt ni de
clause et des famines et sosie au
contraire podium avec une évocation
nostalgique de l'une des plus grandes
idoles des années 70 le portrait plein
de tendresse d'un sosie excessif parce
qu obsessionnelle pour l'incarner benoît
poelvoorde a dû apprendre à chanter et
danser une épreuve
je me sens que le premier jour j'ai vécu
dans une brasserie après son premier
couac mais fera il m'a dit yves jorand
l'argent il on pouvait déjà plus au bout
de deux heures quoi à l'arrivée benoît
poelvoorde et pourtant être clos
renversant
rien
et podium un véritable bain moussant de
disco ou pas une seul payet deux manches
l'épisode françois ont été fabuleux dans
cette histoire parce qu'ils n'ont jamais
jamais embêté et la famille est
satisfaite du résultat
ce qui pour moi une délivrance
fou qu'est ce que vous regardez ni
méchante ni pathétique podium était une
comédie grinçante réussi sur les efforts
désespérés d'un homme pour échapper à
l'anonymat